this morning we look at questions about
a widely used genetic test taken by
hundreds of thousands of people seven
women seven of them and one family had
major surgery after the tests showed
they had a high risk for cancer one of
them says she was left debilitated and
unable to have more children but the
family learned years later that the
results of what's known as the brachot
test might have actually been wrong
their story first appeared in The Wall
Street Journal Jamie yuccas has been
looking at the facts for women
considering genetic cancer screening and
Jamie you can't help but ask how did
this happen I know it's shocking Jericka
genetic testing is a critical part of
assessing cancer risks as well but it's
also an evolving science and as more
people get tested and the technology
improves so do the results unfortunately
in this case the science involved a few
years too late the results that it was
positive it was very alarming
Katie Mathis was in her early 30s
married with a young son when she
decided to take a genetic test to check
her risk for cancer shortly after she
learned she had a mutation on a bracha
gene which significantly raises a
person's risk of developing breast or
ovarian cancer after struggling over
what to do she underwent surgery to
remove her ovaries fallopian tubes and
had a double mastectomy did this end up
changing your life absolutely during the
entire recovery process it was nine
months before I was cleared to pick up
my child but I wasn't able to do bath
time with him I wasn't able to make
dinner for him I wasn't able to pick him
up or hug him for a very long time
her mother sister cousins and aunts all
got tested to 11 had the mutation seven
had surgery but four years later marry
on genetics which did the tests told her
and her family their risk assessment had
changed
I went from very high-risk 84% to
nothing it really felt like I was doing
something for my family I needed to do
these surgeries to save them and then
just the reality that like I didn't need
to do any of that was really heavy
Marriott says such reclassification
are extremely rare and as the science
evolves we scrutinize any new
information and reclassifications are
made only after very careful
consideration this is a changing dynamic
field where we're learning something
every day CBS News medical consultant
dr. David agus says as more people take
genetic tests the results are improving
right now we've tested hundreds of
thousands of people with this BRCA test
every person that's tested and we then
follow the outcome the database gets
stronger we have more information
though reclassifications are uncommon
Mathis says for her the impact is
everlasting
I removed body parts and I can't have
children anymore because of this I just
don't feel like myself and the weight of
that is it's a really big burden and
what do I do each day I have to get up
and keep going you know I'm a mom and a
wife and a teacher so you just keep
going dr. agus says at-risk patients
should get this genetic test he
recommends going though to a National
Cancer Institute designated Center where
counselors can answer your questions
Katy though told me since she no longer
has the cancer classification
she's now worried insurance will not
cover her required follow-up surgeries
Vlad Wow Jamie thank you so much
you